[Music]
back in 1846 whaling was one of the most
booming industries in the whole world it
was the fifth largest sector in the
United States economy raking in a cool
ten million dollars but somewhere along
the way the whale supply started to run
low and some people began to realize
that the entire thing might be a bad
idea how did the whale hunt accelerate
climate change and why were scientists
worried about whale poop shortages this
is what if and here's what would happen
if we never started hunting whales if
the whale hunt never happened there'd be
less carbon in our atmosphere and our
planet would be a lot healthier if we
restored whale populations to pre hunt
levels we could remove about 160,000
tons of carbon from our atmosphere every
year but how can one species be so
important to the entire planet
looking back it's clear why whale
hunting was such an enticing business
opportunity whale meat could be used to
feed the masses their oil could
lubricate machinery and light up a room
their intestines could produce perfume
and their cartilage was perfect for
holding together products like corsets
and umbrellas with all the money wrapped
up in the industry you can see why there
would be such a backlash when it was
essentially banned in 1986 some
politicians even argued that hunting
whales was good for humans because
without whales around to eat fish and
krill there'd be more for us but as we
got rid of the whales the fish and krill
started to die too you see whales are
apex predators which means that they're
the top of their food chain when you
begin to remove the head of a food chain
it creates something called a trophic
cascade basically a trickle-down effect
that can disrupt an entire ecosystem
whales don't just eat fish and krill
they also play a big part in allowing
those populations to thrive for one
thing their poop releases essential
nutrients like iron and nitrogen into
the surface waters which fertilizes
plant plankton which in turn feeds fish
and krill whenever whales swim from the
depths of the ocean back up to the
surface they knock plankton up to the
sunny surface waters allowing it more
time to reproduce the more plankton
there are in our waters the better
things are for everyone not only do
plankton feed lots of marine populations
they also absorb carbon dioxide from our
atmosphere taking it down to the bottom
of the ocean for thousands of years when
they die but the carbon reduction
doesn't stop there
whales also contribute directly to
cleaning up the atmosphere they store
large amounts of carbon and carry it
down to the seafloor when they die
otherwise this carbon would be released
into the environment and contribute to
global warming with all that in mind
it's clear how vital these elegant
creatures are to the planet and how much
good that could have been doing if we
hadn't been slashing their populations
for decades
nowadays whale hunting is banned
everywhere except for a handful of
countries experts say that despite these
efforts the populations of most species
of whale won't even reach half of their
pre whaling numbers by the year 2100
maybe one day we'll be able to make up
for all we lost with the whale hunt but
that's a topic for another what if
[Music]